نيابه عن سيدي خادم الحرمين الشريفين حفظه
الله بعون الله وتوفيقه نفتتح اعمال السنه
الرابعه لمجلس الشورى في دورته الثامنه
ونحمد الله على ما من به علينا من نعم
كثيره وعلى ما تحقق من انجازات ضخمه في
مختلف الاصعده ان بلادكم ماضيه في نهضتها
التنمويه وفق رؤيه 20 30 وبرامجها الطموحه
التي ستسهم بمشيئه الله في محافظه المملكه
على مكانتها المتقدمه عالميا وتحقيق
المزيد من التطور والازدهار وتوفير سبل
الحياه الكريمه
للمواطنين قد حققت بلادنا مراكز متقدمه في
العديد من المجالات بما في ذلك تقدمها في
اكثر من 50% من مؤشرات التنميه المستدامه
للامم المتحده وتطور الاقتصاد السعودي
ليكون اسرع نموا على مستوى دول مجموعه الع
في عام
2022 بمعدل
88.7% نموا في الناتج المحلي وكذلك نمو في
الناتج المحلي الغير نفطي بنحو
4.8%
والوصول ضمن الدول الع الاكثر تنافسيه في
العالم كما حققت في مجال السياحه بلادنا
اداء تاريخيا في الربع الاول من عام
2023 نموا بنسبه 64% وسنواصل العمل في
مسيره التحول الاقتصادي وفق مستهدفات
الرؤيه وان ما تحقق من نتائج ايجابيه يبشر
بالمزيد من النجاحات تحقيق اصلاحات
اقتصاديه وتقويه المركز المالي لمملكه بما
يعزز النمو الاقتصادي الشامل لبلادنا
وحرصا على تسيير اداء مناس الحج والعمره
لاكبر عدد ممكن من الحجاج والمعتمرين فلقد
رحبت المملكه باكثر من 18800 ال حاج ادوا
مناسك الحج واكثر من 10 مليون معتمر خلال
العام الماضي ويعد ذلك من نتائج برامج
خدمه ضيوف الرحمن احد برامج رؤيه 20 30
وانطلاقا من مكانه المملكه التي تحضى بها
في المستويين الاقليمي الدولين وحضورها
المؤثر على جميع الاصعده عملت المملكه على
توثيق علاقاتها البناءه مع الدول الصديقه
والشقيقه حيث استضافت عد عدد من القمم
الكبرى جمعت اكثر من 100 دوله في العام
الماضي وان اختيار المملكه ستضافه معرض
اكسبو 20 30 ياتي تاكيدا لما تحضى به من
مكانه وثقه عالميه وتكون واجهه مثاليه
لاستضافه ابرز المحافل العالميه كما عقدت
المملكه القمه العربيه الاسلاميه المشتركه
الغير عاديه لمواجهه الاحداث المؤلمه التي
تعرض لها شقائنا في غزه عملت المملكه من
خلالها ايجاد حراك عربي واسلامي مشترك
للضغط على المجتمع الدولي نحو اتخاذ مواقف
جاده وحازم ووقف العدوان الاسرائيلي
والسماح بدخول المساعدات الانسانيه الى
قطاع غزه ان نهج المملكه الثابت قائم على
احترام السياده الوطنيه لجميع الدول وعدم
التدخل في شؤونها الداخليه والالتزام
الدائم بمد الشرعيه الدوليه وقراراتها
والتمسك بمبادئ حسن الجوار وحل النزاعات
بالطرق السلميه والاخذ بكل ما من شاننا من
تعزيز الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه
والعالم ستجدون في الكلمه الموزعه عليكم
تفصيلا لسياسه بلادكم الداخليه والخارجيه
ختاما اشكر الاخوه والاخوات في المجلس
وجميع العاملين في اجهزه الدوله الذين
يخدمون وطنهم بكل اخلاص وتفان سائلين الله
ان يوفق الجميع الى ما يحب ويرضى والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته